we had an interesting opening David yeah
just look at how tense this one is and
how imbalanced it is compared to the
previous Berlin when in game one when
Magnus had the white pieces and uh yeah
if we count the pawns to Pieces it's all
level but White Knight is actually
trapped Behind Enemy Lines White's night
on the fifth rank on G5 can't Retreat
can't jump anywhere it's protected by a
pawn but is it a strength is it a
weakness and we also noticed the pawn
imbalance white has four versus three on
the king side on the right half of the
board black has four versus three but a
set of double pawns on the other flank
Black's King in the middle it's unclear
where that's going which side it's going
to Castle on I've seen something similar
to this okay he's hinting now Wesley
that he's going to Castle on the queen
side the left side yeah hang on I was a
little slightly optimistic I must stop
using the British like playing things
down slightly optimistic I think no and
uh there we see Magnus well he's uh
going for an attack you know he's just
saying to Wesley where are you going to
put your king are you going to find
safety on the left side nope because I'm
going to open up some lines there and
the first question is what happens if
Wesley just captures that pawn and I'm
assuming that there's poison because the
white apron will step forward and attack
the Knight if I were them I think I
would do an experiment I you know have
one tournament playing Just country
another one with like heavy metal you
know so most of the time I go through
life thinking I'm not a chess player and
Kyle you're just going to ruin my
illusion
control by Laura something
self-control and do you think he's
sending himself a message and he's
trying to assert control now he's
actually just gone down a pawn Magnus
but he's created a pin with his Queen
Retreat he's trying to keep that control
um okay the Black Brook was undefended
so the black Bishop on the edge couldn't
move but suddenly
that Rook steps back and if evaluation
bar is just so confused I mean I must
admit I'm confused because the fact that
Magnus blitzed into a position where
he's down upon and no immediate way to
compensate to win it back to justify it
confusing to me get going on any good
squares so what is this idea and so he
just moves his Rook over to the B1
Square black is a bit stuck so the one
idea that Magnus had by planting his
Queen on this diagonal it is vulnerable
remember to the black Rook maybe there's
some discovered attacks but the one idea
is that you're covering any King side
castling the black king cannot run
towards this side and I don't think it
wanted to anyway but that is
uh impossible now sure about this
okay Wesley says no I'm not going to
give you time to sacrifice to get active
instead he drops his Bishop back hitting
the White Queen and the White Queen just
jumps out the way and uh first question
that comes to my mind your anchor what
if black goes back so I don't think
black wants to exchange Rooks he does go
back this would only allow White's Rook
access to the open file so instead
Wesley tries to silently offer a draw by
saying okay I'm coming to attack your
queen if you want to keep the game going
you have to run away I do I have an idea
the Knight can jump forward I mean it's
been there in the air to C4
accidentally played the best move but I
mean the Knight coming forward as Magnus
plays now I think not just is it strong
but it's also got psychological uh I
mean it's it's going to be a blow to
Wesley it looks like it wasn't possible
but he plays it sacrificing a knight
remember if it's captured Queen takes
Pawn hitting the Rook the threatening to
come back with a deadly check
uh different posture yeah different
everything and Wesley he's very focused
very professional as we saw there just
kind of uh very stoic but inside yeah he
will be very worried and uh Magnus he
feels like the more creative one who's a
bit more relaxed
freestyling a bit flex King moves so now
there's no more checks on the diagonal
that we talked about but uh yeah Magnus
what will he choose
yeah control control self-control
definitely creating the White Knight
sign of a champion yeah and this UPS the
pressure on Wesley even more you cannot
allow surely the White Knight to go
towards the king but he moves a piece
away from the defense of the king side
wow that's so counterintuitive I've got
to say Wesley feels like he's moving in
the wrong direction but yeah
it's like going
the proof I mean it doesn't make any
sense right you've got to have some
protection around your king
that's the only justification of black
lining help history works together to
defend his Rooks does retreat indeed
but again it feels like the pieces are
on the wrong side of the board Black's
night Black's two Bishops they're not
really helping the defense of their King
the bar does react even further in
White's favor white still has a winning
attack if he can mobilize in the right
way and we're seeing that Trader works
and I do think that he should
forward with his Knight Queen will just
attack the Knight and we see Magnus jump
in to the center yeah do it with your
Bishop in which case white will capture
towards the center and Black's Knight is
offside oh he does retreat the queen I
was going to say here white has a
beautiful Outpost launching pad for his
attack with the Knight now coming in
okay he just leaves this Knight on the
board
and surely now there's a knockout for
Magnus and uh until White's able to
bring in the queen I think he should
hold the position just a little bit
further and then jump in yeah at some
point you can try and bring the queen in
this way like you might need to move
your knight out the way to get to that
diagonal but that's one path
Black Knight now can defend however it's
actually a trademark of one of their
matches in the Euro rapid I do remember
that Magnus always had the advantage in
every single game and then Wesley held
on
until uh Wesley won the match yeah and I
like this move I mean like you say David
I think the Rook will step up to the
second row and wait wait wait wait wait
this move is breaking the rules oh
totally I mean look at the black king
it's in danger and Wesley has gone and
moved the queen all the way to the other
side of the board there has to be a
killer blow and Magnus goes for the
simple approach he just gives a check
hitting the black king now the black
king has to move and now do you capture
the black pawn in the center white
tonight can come back and capture that
you can maybe capture the black Bishop
uh it looks like plenty of options but
Black's King is completely naked it's
devoid of any shelter any defensive
pieces any bodyguards he does trade off
for a bishop and now White Knight is
going to jump in maybe with a fork
hitting the black queen hitting the
Black Brook yeah and uh the queen can
also jump in as well and uh this move is
just a killer blow yeah that's a simple
fork and maybe Wesley was planning to
counter-attack he does go for this if
you move the black queen The Rook would
have fallen but this is the quest this
is the key white continues the attack
hitting the black queen he's also
keeping an eye on the Black Brook
remember and when Black's Queen moves on
the a file she has to White's Queen is
going to go the other direction
it's jumping in now
surely this has to end with Checkmate
white it's attacking with the queen
where it's attacking with a knight black
has no Defenders Queen and Knight are
the ideal attacking Duo as well so
Wesley
surely he can't defend this what is his
rook and queen doing on the wrong side
of the board you called it it's so
unnatural and plus a hundred for right
now that means Checkmate is coming it's
game over yeah no way for that black
king to survive on its own yeah and uh
the sad fact of the matter is the black
king probably has to step forward to the
F7 Square upon which white can just
simply capture a pawn with Chuck
which is like the most straightforward
move in history
so this is not going to end well for
Wesley and he moves his King
to the F line and here you go comes a
check yeah and this will start a series
of checks which will end eventually in
checkmate
Black's King has nowhere safe to hide
you can try to run towards the center
but that won't survive very long that's
uh yeah blacks simply got no defensive
pieces White's Rook at some point can
swing across with some checks
all the poles are actually dropping as
well for black and finally Wesley does
look out the window seeking inspiration
because he needs help he needs a miracle
only way he'll survive
to lose game three and that means he
will have to win game four Wesley so
which will start 10 minutes after this
game finishes the other matches are now
starting their game four we're gonna
jump into Mama Dr of Prague they are
tied before that game four when this one
finishes it looks like it will finish
with a win or Magnus Carlsen to take the
lead in this big match against Wesley so
yeah this will be a massive win uh I
thought these two on paper at least
they're the favorites for this
tournament
and Magnus striking in early blue he
gives a check with his Knight the black
king retreats
it's too many tempting moves here for
Magnus that's the that's the only
problem Maybe
I think I would if I were playing I
would simply capture the pawn and
introduce the white Rook into the game
and Wesley shaking his head yeah there's
a choice of Pawns to capture I'm
guessing you want to capture with white
death porn yeah just open up the f file
yeah looks very good white tonight could
go and capture the black Bishop white so
I can go and capture a Pawn on that side
as well it does capture the black Bishop
so now the white Rooks opened from this
this angle and uh on the seventh rank
what can be done Black's Knight is
trying to hold on its own it can't yes
you can give a check to the white king
but White's King has got a perfectly
safe Square hiding hole on the H2 Square
nothing no way you can attack it there
no no way the black queen can come
forward and defend her King and it is
going to be game over Wow first result
uh today between Magnus Carlsen and
Wesley so Magnus Scrolls and takes the
lead in the match against his big rival
from last season Wesley so